going to get a good stream in probably
seven, eight hours. Um, not my usual and
plus for Saturday, but it is Valentine's
Day.
There we are.
Hey, Pepe. Stream work on Saturday.
Saturday is usually my longest day,
Alex.
So, I think today is just going to be
seven, eight, seven or eight hour
stream.
let's see where we want to start today.
First of all, let's just check if I have
anybody messaging me. Uh, do we have
anything from Peru or Jonah?
No. Okay, so neither of those two
contributors. Hey Jan, welcome.
Believe Peru is still doing some
profiling stuff on uh environments
and we also have uh going to doing some
kernel stuff. So I think there are few
goals I have today. I really want to get
this into a spot where we can make
um generally make broader use of this.
I guess they
let's here let's just take a few minutes
to go through the remaining complexity
because we did this
we did this.
This is still to do
remaining complex.
So we have
uh a whole ton of initraphing
in
upperland cpp
I don't know how to fix this while
leaving torch in
to
was it plus one
layer in direction
because of kernel verse native torch
path.
Is it one layer or two layers?
Two layers, isn't it?
It would just be launch.
So we can consider making this one
layer.
Has it gotten busier and are we getting
less streams init? So, I would say
temporarily
because I have I am personally working
on three client contracts and Puffer's
got four of them active, four or five,
four main ones active. Um, and one of
them we just signed is a much bigger
one.
So, I have a fair bit of client stuff to
take care of, and it was supposed to be
spaced out, but over the holidays, a
couple clients didn't get me stuff when
they said they would, so everything is
stacked up at the same time. So, at
least a few days a week now, I need to
be doing some of that.
Uh, that said, there I'm also in
Florida. Florida's a little bit less
productive than Maryland for me because
there's like travel time to and from gym
and stuff and, you know, I got stuck in
traffic like an hour yesterday. There's
all sorts of things that get in the way.
Uh, that said, there will still be
streams. I'm still aiming to get like a
minimum of three solid stream days in a
week, and I'd like to be doing more than
that as well, but that's what I've got
bandwidth for at the time being.
I'm here like seven I think seven eight
hours today
contract work we doing. So um what the
heck happened to my camera?
All right. Uh so professionally Puffer
builds high performance RL SIMs and we
solve RL problems for people like that
is the business. So all of Puffer's open
source. Um but Puffer is a company. It's
a couple companies actually and uh we do
offer professional stuff.
We were assessing all the remaining
complexity in here.
minor
on
It's like 750 lines of code that doesn't
do anything, right?
Like if you think about it, the torch
modules really doesn't do anything at
all.
I think that is most of the remaining
complexity though
Okay. So I think then the the one thing
I let's let's at least figure this
problem out real quick first this
indirection thing. Um so the way I have
it
I have this like if kernels Oops.
Right? So I have all of these functions
down here that have this if kernels
path.
Right? If kernels do this, otherwise do
this.
I think I just did it this way because I
have like the custom nets have to do it
this way, right?
Oh, I mean there's also like it's
because there there like these chunks of
shared logic that are kind of annoying,
right?
Like I see where this complexity is
coming from. I understand why we have it
and I see how we're going to get rid of
it in the future, but I don't see if
there's a clean way to get rid of it
now.
we have a couple things we can do. There
are a few minor things where I know I'm
going to find some areas for clean up.
There's like the general just calling
through the code trying to fix things.
Um,
we really want to be able to start
running experiments. I'm trying to think
like what would be the thing that is
going to help us the most
for 4
and I think it is really to just start
getting some of the experiments
going in stable
like there's going to be some cleanup I
have to do for the Python side that's
annoying but not particularly hard.
I have a bunch of writing to do. I have
a bunch of like minor refactoring to do,
but I think for a feature complete like
basically stable and ready,
we mainly just need to have the
experiment results um and such in
constellation.
Let me go take a quick look at those
results then.
I say I'm trying to figure out what we
do about that though other than um
like what do we do about this other than
just running the experiments?
like okay maybe I should explain because
this is probably not obvious to people.
So
puffer is working perfectly. Uh the
sweeps is working perfectly. What this
is saying is that the best hypers found
for 2048
have a clip coefficient of 0.01
which is the minimum possible.
And like look at all these experiments
that are pretty well performing.
And then this is another set of sweeps I
did where I kept I capped it to be no
less than 0.1. It's way worse.
I suppose this could be a bug with how
we have buffer
implemented. I'm going to try two
different things.
Let me sanity check. I think this is
equal to sign this out.
I think it ends up being signed this
time.
Yeah. See, this is where the LLMs
completely fall apart. The system say
that can't possibly be. Well, I have the
result right here.
Okay. Um,
second possibility.
Are we supposed to update
values is the question.
I think it might be because we're
updating values here. So, I'm
essentially I'm trying to figure out why
it's doing this ridiculous clipping. We
do have a couple things weird.
Unfortunately, I probably have some
proper look like code in the training
data for claw at this point.
I just want to bounce some stuff because
I'm basically here. I'm pretty sure that
the ratio update is correct. It's
possible the value update isn't
because there kind of two possibilities
here, right? One is that we're just
doing a really wide hyper sweep and
we're discovering weird trends that
people don't notice before. And the
other is that some of the stuff we've
done in Puffer 3 is kind of jank and uh
produces these weird trends and like
we're basically just making stuff stable
in spite of it by clipping hyperpar
sweep ranges.
values rewards. I mean the thing is this
does give you the advantage estimate.
I think possibly it's the important
sampling is wrong.
What do you think about Prime Intellect?
They're funny. Um, they do LLML though.
Like, it's pretty different stuff. And I
don't really follow a ton of LMRL.
I have one of the group chats I'm in on
X is like prime people.
Are we getting the importance values
correct?
I'm a little confused.
Roll out ratio.
Where am I computing ratio?
This computer train loss
launch videos are gorgeous.
I haven't seen any of them. I do need to
get
I need to figure out what I'm going to
do for
I'm probably going to have a nice launch
video.
Hey user
aesthetics of launch video. I mean,
honestly, at the end of the day, it's
the whole the cold hard thing that
you've built matters the most.
And like, yeah, you can lose on the
other stuff, but
hey, you're not going to win on it.
So, I guess lo and win versus blood,
right?
It's kind of impossible to lose if
you're not on a tight like funding burn
rate.
I know more and more lately I found
clarity in just ignoring
what all the other startups and all the
other labs and stuff are doing and just
solving the problem.
I will do a few things for the puffer 4
release though just so that people see
it.
But until then, I think we just make
sure that we actually make it good.
ratio out
this old log props
The main questions I have in my mind at
the moment are like,
can I make this thing good enough to
ship with torch in it like this? Um,
you know, at what point is it going to
make sense to rip out torch completely?
to what extent can I like provide chunks
of my stuff to binding as bindings to
the Python version to give at least the
Python users some level of performance.
These are the questions I have in my
mind.
Yes. Okay. So I think I think I do
actually have
a problem on value function change here
that billion compared to his peers.
What peers
There are a few br like brilliant
brilliant people in AI. Um, but for the
most part, it's just a lot of the people
that you look up to are actually
complete morons
is more the way that it goes. I think
that's true in a lot of places.
There are very very few actual geniuses
but there are very large number of
morons pretending to be useful.
Um
and Ilia was always quite sharp, quite
precient,
very very well spoken and not in a
bullshitty way either.
You always had a lot of respect for him.
Dario. Sam. Okay, Sam should not be on
that list at all. Sam is a [ __ ]
common. Uh, Radford's awesome.
Daario is at least technically capable
and very smart, but completely
delusional.
So, that's like the most mismatched list
ever right there.
Nice cup. Thank you. I'm thinking I
should get a bigger one. This one's too
small.
Well, I see why the VF The co would be
pushed really down.
Okay, so you're clipping grad to a max
norm, right?
I'm trying to think what else would
cause this issue.
So, I definitely see a spot where we
could be screwing up our VF clipping.
And that's a very longstanding thing
with puffer. Um, is VF clip co being
pushed down. So, I could see this being
a very useful enhancement
I don't see anything that would push the
clip to down.
Guess maybe the fact that it cranks up
the replay ratio.
Why the heck would it crank up the
replay ratio? That also seemed weird to
me.
Yeah. Look,
why we have um why we have noticeably
better results with a higher replay.
That's super sketchy.
Oh,
hang on.
I think this is a bug then.
Oh, this is evil.
Yeah. Yeah, this is evil.
Okay,
let me see if this is actually correct.
Dot contiguous allocates a new tensor.
It is a copy, not a view.
I think that this is correct.
hang on.
Roll out buffer.
The right facts go to paparall.roll
rollouts.
The reads come from roll out star.
Do that.
This is such a big bug. If we find this,
but I plan a lot.
So then this is basically just never
updating this code, huh?
let's let's do one thing first.
Let me let me actually understand what
this would cause first. This is very
very important we get this right. Um
this could fix the remaining problems
with buffer and then this could
literally be we fix this in our next
sweep's work and then basically it's
just pure clean up to forum.
This is how substantial this would be if
this is actually what's happening here.
Uh and this would also the other thing
that we just found would also resolve a
long-standing hyperpar issue we've had
with buffer
You don't ever update ratio. You don't
ever update value.
And what happens?
Red swag.
This means ratio is always one.
You just don't have important sampling
on this.
I think you still have important
sampling on the segment level,
but this basically nulls puff advantage.
That would make sense why the um the
values for that are all over the place.
Does that explain why it wouldn't have a
super low clip though?
Oh, it's because um sampling the same
thing over and over, right?
I think it does explain it.
So, the aggressive clips would be
because we're sampling the same thing
over and over,
repeatedly sampled. Yeah.
Okay.
Uh if this does not immediately solve
breakout, we are not going to be sad
because we absolutely will have to re
sweep after this.
Okay. So,
Wrong index segments,
right?
Yes, that's fine.
Okay. So, if this does not solve
breakout, we're fine as long as it
learns something. If this learns
nothing, we're a little bit suspicious.
Uh, we still have to solve the value bug
though.
Okay. You know, it still does reasonably
well. Completely off hypers.
We're still at
Well, that was weird. It got 600 and
something one run and then you saw it
got nothing the next run.
Super unstable is fine.
I think we just need to add all the
values to roll out B.
I'm just having this essentially do
extra checks. You know, unfortunately, I
I am sort of acknowledging that this um
the way I have Puffer now, it's not
really great for being able to make
quick little edits to things and have
all of the code context in your head.
It's good for research in the sense that
it lets you just run a [ __ ] ton of
experiments.
I mean, it's also way simpler and faster
than the other higher code bases, but we
do trade a little bit of simplicity off.
MB returns is now advantages plus old
values. Yes.
Okay. So, it's unstable, but it does
train
So, we've completely broken breakout
training.
What on earth are we taking all this
time doing?
How the heck do we get batch 2730?
Oh, three buffers.
Okay, we're going to kill this
We're just going to assume that
something is wrong here.
Do like this.
But what is wrong with this? Why is this
taking so long to make a new run?
Oh, it's probably one editing, right?
No.
Forward.
The heck is going on here?
mini batch size? It could be setting
weird, I guess.
See if within a few runs I find
something non-trivial.
BF losses are insane.
Wait, are they always insane?
Yeah, there's no way that lambda should
be 0.6.
we go. Right
immediately something reasonable at
least.
That ought to seed it with something.
Math domain error. Lovely.
Okay,
I think we've got stable speed.
I'm going to let this run. Um,
I will be back in a few and I'm going to
do a couple things. Get myself a cup of
tea and then we will see if we have
fixed cover lip. I'll be back.
Oh, well that looks good. At least we
are um
Yeah, those are real runs. Cool.
We did ban this bot.
I'm going to get my uh my tea
and
then we shall see.
I think I might have just fixed a super
longstanding puffer bug though and a
really bad puffer core bug. I think we
just did both at once.
Uh that would be exciting if so.
I'm here. I have an excuse. When asked
to make breakfast on Valentine's Day,
you make breakfast on Valentine's Day.
140 experiments already.
Lovely. Oh, beautiful. Look at this clip
go up.
Very reasonable via clip costs.
I think these are slow though, right?
Not even that slow.
Let's see.
Say six seconds.
4 seconds. Yeah, this will be this will
be good, guys.
Um, holy,
I think we just found
I mean, if this is the case and this is
the biggest like bug fix uh to Puffer in
a year.
Well, I mean, it's like a moderate bug
fix I think to puffer three and a very
very huge one for four.
But this should push us under three
seconds.
Hey, Liberty. Uh, I think we just found
a massive bug in Puffer 4. And it's the
good type of bug. It's the type of bug
where your results are still valid and
your results should be much better after
you fix it.
uh the bug was essentially it's using
the wrong uh using a new value function
for the target in VF clip will mess up
your clipping and then specific in
puffer 4 we were not copying data
correctly
uh to update the new value and new
ratios for advantage.
So we were using stale advantage
function.
Even if this doesn't get us faster
solves, if this gets us the same solve
speed as before and stops us getting
super jank hyper prams out of our
sweeps, I will be very happy because
honestly, like the jank hypers thing is
the one thing that still just has me
annoyed where it's like, you know, maybe
RL's still a mess.
149 experiments as well since I just
went down to make breakfast.
Super fast.
Well, here's what I'm going to do. Uh, I
went and I made breakfast. I'm going to
go grab my plate and um I'll Sit here.
We'll let this run for a bit. I'll have
some breakfast. Oh, perfect. One moment.
Okay, we'll let me just watch we'll
watch this for a little bit while I have
some breakfast here. Um, and then
I guess I I want to let this run a
bunch. So, while we're getting full
data, I will I'll commit this. I'll move
dev to my local and we'll just like
we'll do some of the cleanup that we
were going to do. We'll do stuff where
we're very unlikely to break anything.
Um
and then once this has gotten a full
sweep by later in the day, if the
results are good, then we'll queue up
and then hopefully we get a 2048 sweep
with less jank hypers. And if we get
that, then it's GG. We win.
This bit purely just came from like
thinking about the experiment data a
bunch over the last couple days for
reference.
I don't know why the hell there's an
experiment in there at like 70 plus up
time. That's weird. But
oh, whatever.
Oh, I just noticed I just noticed. Look
at the um
look at all the names. They're all
Valentine's Day themed.
See, this is how you know that
Weights and Biases is a professional
company because if I were going to make
um custom named experiments for
Valentine's Day, they would all be like
log off touch graphs.
Does this stupid dictionary do this?
Just letting
I mean, an most of the um
most of the hype is [ __ ]
AI research is not at all automated.
That's why they're still hiring tons of
people and pouring billions and billions
of dollars into R&D. Um they have more
researchers now than they ever have
before.
So,
most of that stuff is a type and
[ __ ] and you kind of just need to
know what you're doing.
So, don't spend a ton of time like
trying to learn to use AI tools to help
you or whatever because they're dumb.
Um, there they have no learning curve if
you do want to use them. The thing that
still has a learning curve is like
low-level dev architectures, algorithms,
um, all the tensor shenanigans that go
on. like all the normal stuff is still
the normal stuff.
So I guess don't overindex on AI or
We getting some more. reasonable values.
Oh yeah,
these are reasonable values.
Matched learning rate.
Yeah, I'm going to finish my toast.
We're going to sync this up and um then
we'll start cleaning some things up.
Okay,
we let this do its thing here for a bit.
I mean, now I'm going to just be wanting
to look at this all day,
but
The best thing is to let this run and
like focus on other stuff. Um, okay. So,
if this this is the case, then
stuff to clean up.
A few things.
Kind of don't want to mess with the
sweeps code because of that though.
Let's go check our roll out buffers.
I want to see how we're using these.
Yeah, I really like I really do not like
this.
Okay, I think there will have to be a
little bit of plotting today, but like
not for I think it's going to be mostly
a couple basic cleanup things that I've
missed.
So, like very uh well-defined stuff.
I still hate that I'm doing it this way
though.
What's the alternative though?
We could totally just inline it, can't
we?
Well, wait. No, the problem is that we
want to have it profiled, right?
Yeah, we can't inline it because we want
to have it profiled, right? That was the
problem.
Let me see. I remember.
This type of work ends up being a little
bit slow because it ends up mostly being
me just like thinking about how do I
make this code not suck.
I mean, it's it's one of these things
where like I know exactly how users are
going to feel looking at this. Like,
well, how do I do this in a way that
they don't hate this? um
while also letting me still be able to
profile it correctly and all that
cuz right now it's function here
because it's defined in models and then
it's defined in modules.
I think it's one redundant layer of
abstraction, right?
This one's easy. We just do this.
Boom.
We take the thick.
Right.
And then we unindent this entire thing
by one.
Okay. So we can start with that.
if
papers.
Okay. Right.
Else
thing.
So ignore the fact that these sigs are
massive for now, right?
And do the exact same thing here.
Let's
copy this.
Yes, that's the exact same thing.
Cool. So, we take this
and then compute file.
We just do if kernels
Can we do that?
We totally can, can't we?
same length minus one layer of
abstraction
or rather one layer of indirection I
should say kind of same thing
Is there any um there shouldn't be any
overhead following it this way, right?
I don't think there should be.
All right. What about this one? Like
compute train loss. How about this?
I mean, I don't see any reason to have
this be um separate. Do you
It's a really simple. You shouldn't be
using it for very heavy stuff anyways.
But why am I reaching for this?
I shouldn't be reaching for stupid
Claude.
There's something about the code that's
wrong if I am.
I It's literally just a shitty torch and
I don't like touching it, right?
I don't do this when I'm writing. See,
sometimes I ask it about math and stuff,
but I end up writing the code.
What happens if I just try to edit this
manually? What happens?
You get PO loss
optimized function. Ah, okay. So, this
is why this is why I'm reaching for
Claude, right? Because watch what I have
to do for this [ __ ]
I end up having to like
This goes this gets a dot apply.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Now I know why I'm
reaching for it. Okay. This is actually
not a bad thing then. This is not me
being lazy.
is it okay if I use path binding in an
environment? I don't know if this is
considered cheating. Well, for what?
Like we have a couple environments, I
think, that use path finding. Um, the
enemy AI uses pathfinding in MOA. That's
a very common one.
Um there are definitely cases where like
if like path finding is appropriate. Now
the thing you got to be careful is path
finding can be very slow. Um so if you
can cache it if it's a very small map
it's often possible to cache all
possible pathf finding ops that tends to
be useful. In fact uh the Runescape
environment that I have like the
Runescape thing that I have is going to
require uh a very efficient AAR
implementation.
funny enough. So like there is there is
absolutely case for pathf finding. I
think usually you use it for the enemy
AI and then for human control.
You can use it for the agent, but I
don't know if it makes the problem
easier a lot of the time.
Like what are you going to what do you
want to do with it? I suppose is the
question.
So, the reason that I want that I find
myself using claw here is because torch
is shitty and all the code is super
redundant. Lo and behold,
um, we just try to make the code a
little less redundant today. That's all.
There's going to be a limit on how well
we can do it, but
And we can start
quick experiment update.
Not bad.
2.9 seconds for 744.
Old bomber mechanic. We have randomly
roaming enemies
under the target.
Oh, dude. Like that. Yeah, puffer will
just insta solve that. Like the puffer
doesn't need path finding. If you want
the enemies to have path finding, sure.
Like it tougher is really really good.
Any of these sort of relatively simple
arcadey task, it'll just insta solve as
soon as you have the ends correct.
Sometimes I have rewards stalling.
Have you looked at what the model is
doing? Have you tried to play the game
yourself? Have you looked at the obs?
Have you looked at the reward? Like
if it's a if it's the game that I'm
thinking it it is, um, puffer will insta
solve. So,
most of the time I see a lot of the
newer contributors around here, they try
to get too fancy on their M to make it
easier for the RL. But you got to
understand the RL's really, really
freaking good. And most of the time it's
you've done something silly with this M
or you have silly hyper, you know, or
silly reward or something like that.
What is reward stolen? Like they didn't
gain reward uh just like the thing stops
learning, right? Like reward plateaus.
Okay. So,
cool.
What the [ __ ]
Deviation value
props.
Hey Lo.
Hey Ashwin. What are you working on?
Looks interesting. I believe you're new
here. So this is development on Puffer
Lib. Puffer lib is the highest
performance reinforcement learning
library. We have a bunch of demos here
on uh on puffer.ai.
We currently have training in dev over
15 million steps per second on a single
GPU which means you can do RL on simple
to medium complexity tasks in seconds
and quite hard ones and minutes often
times. Uh I stream all the development
on it at the moment. This is a mix of
refactoring stuff up for the next
release, fixing some major algorithmic
bugs, running tons of experiments, going
back and forth and checking those. lots
and lots and lots of dev work on uh on
the project overall. It's all open
source
and uh sometimes you'll also see me
working with contributors on stream as
well.
That's the idea around here.
and then this should just be one path.
One shot League of Legends with Grock.
Not happening.
If they're not training specifically on
League, it will be a complete failure. I
don't know what his his deal is with AI
lately because I mean he's kicking ass
with SpaceX and Tesla and a lot of his
other stuff, but some of the AI comments
are just completely [ __ ] dumb.
And I don't think Brock is anywhere near
as bad as um like a lot of the other
people are saying. Like the lab overall,
it's doing decently well, especially for
how small it is and how recent it is.
But some of the stuff like just doesn't
make any goddamn sense.
Like literally, how does that even make
sense? Like, oh, okay. You're going to
make really, really good AI trained on a
bunch of stuff, but not specifically
League of Legends. Cool. So, there's not
a single person in the world that can
one-shot League of Legends without
having played the game quite a bit.
I don't even think that there's a single
person that can like
who's never played League or at least
like a very adjacent game can get to top
of ELO bracket within even a couple of
months. Like it takes a [ __ ] ton of
practice and domain specific experience,
not in the training data.
Now look, if they're going to fine-tune
on the data and they're going to do
like, you know, uh gameplay like pixels
on that, uh they're going to train on
pixels and like sure they can get an
inefficient thing that works, but I
think that the best possible case for
them is that they get a less impressive
result, a less impressive version of
OpenAI 5
because OpenAI 5 like was already done
and it's the best best result in RL.
Well,
dare say otherwise.
Already did this.
Wait, what?
Okay, I think you can do this. I think
the I think you're allowed to do this.
Okay, this is going to be some weird
torch thing.
One path
Yeah, this some C++ jank.
This is some C++ jank.
Terrible language really.
Probably the sigs are different.
They should be the same.
Oh, there you go.
Hello, chief puffing officer. Long time.
How's it going?
We are doing some simple refactoring of
stuff
to make the code less awful
and we are waiting on a bunch of
experiments to run.
This is not bad. We've got um
it does seem we're getting this elbow
though around 5 seconds now, which is
concerning.
It should not be slower after the
update.
It should be substantially better if
anything.
How many hours do you work in a week? It
depends.
I mean, I mostly work when I feel like
working.
I mean, I started a little bit late
today and I'm ending a little bit early
since it's Valentine's Day.
Okay,
we're not expecting this to solve for
reference. Um, these are untuned pars.
Yeah,
got plans later, but working right now.
See if we can understand why
why it's like this.
I don't think we need this
at all. Right.
autograd wrapper. So you see this gross
thing like look these functions already
have big signatures and then you end up
having all these like these dumb
wrappers around this.
It's required by the PyTorch C++ API.
You have to register a torch autograd
function subclass
Let's see. What do we call this?
What's this AI you're using?
Which AI?
If you mean this, this is just flawed,
which is totally stupid, but it's fine.
Like, I'm not using it to do AI. I'm
using it to apply very well- definfined
refactor operations to very stupid code.
These AIs are things that I've trained.
Some of these are my environments. Most
of them are contributed environments
uh that are now part of Puffer Lib. And
these ones train super fast. These are
tiny little models.
Yeah, that's a nice rate factor up
internet and typing speed.
Well, the internet better be fast
because this is this machine um I'm on.
First of all, this is just an SSH
instance. I could easily have this and
then latency would not be a factor. Um,
but yeah, this is part of the puffer
cluster. I think we still have pictures
on the website.
This was the old one. Where's the new
puffer cluster?
stupid thing
here. I'll show you the new puffer
cluster. I'm usually streaming from
there most of the year, but summer and
winter I'm elsewhere.
have the uh
Oh, yeah, there it is.
We got all the machines in the
background. We got the uh the gym and
compute cluster uh combo.
It'll be fun. I'll be back there in a
month or two.
Do you work off liveream? Yeah, but I
mostly just do client work off stream.
So most of the uh open source dev
streamed
and sometimes I stream a little bit of
client work if it happens to be open
source
but most of our client work is like post
Sims.
That's sick. Yeah, it's a fun setup.
I mean, I'm kind of in the middle of
nowhere there, so I sort of have to have
all my own stuff.
Um,
and there's lots of space, so why not?
You'd be shocked how cheap some of the
uh the gem equipment is. Like that whole
dual tower stack I think was maybe two
grand.
Iron Man 3.
Why three?
The original was perfectly good. No.
I think that's like the only um
not even really superhero but adjacent
movie I've ever seen was the original
Iron Man.
That one's pretty cool because that's
like actually kind of what nerds want to
do is just have their own lab and build
cool [ __ ] in peace.
I need to add the rappers back.
Hello.
Part of the point of this was to delete
the rappers.
Does Paul apply directly?
[ __ ]
is modules.h.
So we can't call unless the class is
visible
minimal class
in
stupid.
Everything in AI is just named the
opposite of what it is. I swear
reasoning models can't reason. Open AI
closed. Enthropic is misanthropic.
Every blooded time.
Okay, this is totally fine. Just minimal
decks.
C++. I swear
I can't wait until the day that we just
delete torch entirely and we just do raw
food up. That'll be so much better.
I don't know what dystopian hell we've
ended up in where like people have just
stopped giving a [ __ ] and are just
submitting AI slop code and uh even
though they're not bothering to read
their stuff anyways, they're still doing
it in like Python and TypeScript and
crap. Like at the very least, if you're
going to automate yourself out of the
loop and you submit like some nice C
code or something,
like those languages were created so
your dumb ass could understand in the
first place. So, if you're not going to
even bother, we may as well just have C.
Ah, okay.
I didn't know you could do this.
But then again, I don't really write
C++. So, I actually like this more.
I actually like this a lot more.
This is going to be way nicer, right?
Cuz look,
yeah, now these look like functions.
These are now just functions tied to
strrus.
So,
I always hate the extra indent level
from classes.
This is actually way if we have to do
this, this is probably the way to do it.
That's way better.
And uh I highly doubt this breaks it
with this simple refactor.
Yeah, it's literally just moving like
class definition under too. I didn't I
legitimately didn't know that you could
do this in C++.
That actually makes me like the C++
classes way more.
Nowhere near enough to use them by
choice, but
It's going to make it a lot easier to
port to uh to see because you basically
just delete those deaths. You're good.
I'm excited to see how much code we've
deleted by doing this.
Can't take its address in the same way.
Really?
Static member function template can't
take its address in the same way.
That's gig of [ __ ] though.
That's a
disaster. That is
[ __ ] C++. I swear
you could do this and say
Every single time I come up with
something like reasonably clean, I end
up butting heads with the torch code
just being absolute unadulterated
garbage.
Like, what the [ __ ] is this
variatic template?
Why does this exist?
who came up with this and thought,
"Yeah, let's do this."
So now, even though I have a function
that takes the exact same argument list,
I can't just decide, let me use the
function pointer
like this. Instead, let's rewrite the
entire function out like this, or wrap
the function in yet another layer of
indirection for absolutely no reason.
This is why we don't have nice things.
Programmers are idiots.
I'm trying to think how I want to handle
this.
Okay, I think I know what I'm going to
do. Uh, one second.
had to go answer some questions. Hello,
Jess. What are we up to today? We are We
fixed a major bug
and there's no timeline, but we're still
working on it.
I think that will work. Um, where did
our experiment go?
4.4
5.29 29.
The [ __ ] is this?
Absolute imbecile.
Apply because autograd needs to track
individual tensors.
Annoying.
So, we can't even do that. There can
just be no nice things.
Thanks, Torch.
Well, we're sure not doing this
idiot language model.
I'm trying to think what we can do.
I mean, on one hand, I don't want to
spend all of my time today fighting
Torch's just stupid code. Um, like there
are a million ways that I could do this
and Torch is just blocking all of them.
Lovely shitty anonymous function
bindings. My favorite.
I swear programmers are some of the
smartest and some of the dumbest people
you will ever meet.
I mean, it's like when you see stuff
that's just so simple and clean and
takes a hard problem and just like
cleanly splits it up into like this and
this and this. It's like, you know, it's
just very very clear logic. Honestly,
some of the closest it's like the
closest thing out there to just clear up
pure thought in my mind. But then you
see like people that they go like, "Oh,
we need to solve A to B to C. Let's do A
to D to Z to G to F to E and then let's
split off into H and K and I and J. And
then maybe eventually we'll get back to
C.5." What's C.5? Well, it's as close as
we get to C.
Yeah, I think we're probably only going
to keep the torch C++ back end for like
one major update anyways and then it'll
be into um just CUDA.
Oh, we're updating kernels. Good.
I mean, the profile for kernels good.
It's at least nice.
I do at least want to see if we saved
some code by doing this.
There's only so much I can do with uh
torch being the way it is,
but I'm going to do my best to at least
get this to be reasonable.
It's getting closer to being human
editable finally.
68 688. I believe that's minus 150ish
lines.
and then we'll see whether this does
anything better for us.
Okay, the thing I wanted to look at here
before I got distracted
uh was
We got a couple sketchies here. I think
we got a couple sketchies.
We'll have to double check this.
Oh, what's this? We got a 4.3 second
solve.
Cool. So, we're actually we are making
some progress.
Yeah, this will clean up. This will save
us a few lines.
688.
And we've got a whole bunch of advantage
craft that's going to get compressed.
Oh, and torch tensor. Hello.
Yeah, it doesn't have the using depths.
Okay, so we have a lot to clean up then.
Sadly, it doesn't make the most sense to
just be doing this with plot at the
moment, which is kind of annoying, but
our file S file
codeex person. They both suck, dude.
Look at what I'm doing with them.
I'm doing very, very stupid refactor
operations that would take a long time
because there's a bunch of crap code.
Such like a nononsense person. I can be.
He's good.
I mean, realistically, like, can we just
send the claw code build for uh this
refactor to the torch team instead? Cuz
it's their [ __ ] code is the reason
that this is such a mess and it needs to
be cleaned up this much.
Best third party library you haven't
needed. Ray lib. Rail. You want good
software.
This is good software. This is how to
write code and not be a [ __ ]
Like every single part of this project
is just great.
Here's their math.
Here's Ray math.
you go look at their docs.
They have awesome just like simple cheat
sheet docs plus lots of examples.
Everything is super succinct and simple.
This library is a joy to work with.
Like if you want to just like see what
it feels like to work with good software
versus bad software, play around with
Rail.
It's like, wow, I enjoy programming. Oh,
that's what it says on the front page.
library to enjoy programming. Yay. And
then you go torch and it's like I have
thrifting depression.
It's like I can't even twist my brain
into this like idiot space that it would
have to be in to design some of the crap
that's in this library.
Code is just awful.
when you're going to convince him to
start writing some ends. Rayson, he's
got better stuff to do.
Rayson does enough building Rayb.
If any of you are using Rayb, go check
him a couple bucks a month though on um
on GitHub. It actually really helps him
out a lot. I don't ask for donations for
Popper. We do our stuff B2B. Uh he
doesn't, so that actually helps him a
lot.
And of course, Puffer is one of the
sponsors as well.
Okay. How much order is it? 670
lines.
Okay,
that's at least
substantially better.
Now we have 656 lines. That's minus 200
from earlier today at the very least.
and popular C++ 811.
Uh I think we're still down lines from
earlier despite having had to have done
one growth thing
which is
yeah these
couple growth functions.
Copy function still fine. Advantage
function still fine. pretty much just
this thing.
Good. That's what we expect. This is not
supposed to solve. His hypers are um bad
but this is what we expect overall in 6
seconds uh is matching per before
good
very very good
120 line commit.
Minus 120 line commit is nice.
We're always down to strip more code.
Getting harder to cut code though. You
know, that was um a good couple hours of
work for minus 120.
It was a good minus 120 though. It
should have been more.
Um
it should have been like substantially
more,
Uh okay. So we have
800 in puffer lib
some more in models.
Then we have
kernels modules are shorter.
Generally pretty happy. Generally pretty
happy.
So I suppose then where is his remaining
complex state?
This is fine. This is uh [ __ ] bindings.
We can maybe look at this, but there's
not going to be much to do here.
These are all our models.
This includes
yeah, our default model and a bunch of
our like C++ backends is fine.
Custom models fine. Um, most of this we
can probably save a little bit here, but
like
not too much.
End finding moan modules
huffernet.h
H
this is separate that's not a thing
and the big files kernels possibly
there's some savings in there modules is
now at least substantially cleaned up
maybe some in there
I mean we're probably within 500 lines
of the um
we're probably within like 500 lines
We can just delete squared CU and
squared torch. If we don't decide to do
GPU ends,
uh we could decide to do GPU ends. It
would be super simple.
Honestly, at this point,
the uh
really the only two significant things
left
are
like there's going to be minor cleanup
and I have to spend some time on it but
the only significant things are whether
there is some savings in Envc still.
Uh I got a chat with Peru about that
and
how our sweeps are going
overall.
I think those are the two only two
significant things
unless I keep finding more of these like
um more of these random cleanups.
But I that to me seems like the last big
one we're going to get.
Uh cuz that was like a pretty nice find
and it's only minus 120,
right?
Skip is four.
Skip is
Oh, actually this is kind of what we
were expecting, right?
496 total agents
and frame
this
and
BF clip.
total time steps
is 94 million.
We get everything.
I think we got everything.
Yeah, Jess, I think that we are Holy
crap. Um,
well,
Where's the SPS on this? Well, it's not
going to tell me, right? That's going to
be crazy SPS. That's 13 mil SPS on my
low-end machine for reference,
right? Yeah, that's 13 mil framed on my
low-end machine. That's insane.
And that's a solve.
That is a solve.
Yeah, this is going to be way better, I
think.
I'm not disappointed by the smaller nets
either. Like that's kind of what we
expected from the update. Simpler and
would make use of smaller nets.
So just uh there was a major major major
bug fix today
and it requires us to rerun a bunch of
sweeps and retest some stuff.
Um but that's kind of what I'm working
on.
I also got a nice refactor in minus
another 120 lines for us.
That's good to have.
Let's just detach this so I don't kill
this weed by mistake. Put this on my
other monitor. In fact,
what was the FPS on this?
Oh, yeah. 23 million FPS training.
Yeah, cool.
Okay.
23 million SPS.
That's um to be fair. So that's fewer
agents which should be worse. But then
that is um more uh what is it? Fewer
agents and smaller network size.
So that's not like um that's not a perf
improvement benchmark. All right.
But that's still nuts.
23 million steps per second.
What was the bug waiting thing? No,
Jess, that's not the thing in the
Discord is very minor. This is a much
more major thing I found. It's kind of
complicated. It had to do with how we
were computing um how we were updating
rollout buffers.
Essentially, it wasn't able to use any
of the prior replay stuff if it wanted
to. and uh it wasn't able to correctly
clip value functions. There were several
things wrong. One of the bugs was
actually in 30 as well. So, this should
even give us a qualitative boost over
300 now that we're fixing it.
And here's our 4.3 though.
546 experiments run.
This is everything I've always wanted
with buffer. This is everything I've
always wanted. Um, we will let this
finish. We'll find something else to do
in the meantime while we run this
patch be added to 30 just for jazz, but
we'll also add it to the Python back end
for 40
because you really you have to re sweep
everything is the problem. It's like
there are two types of bugs, right?
There's the bug where like oh no, we had
a bug or results are invalid. Uh this
was not one of those. This was like one
of the bugs where ah we had a bug. Oh,
our results get even better once we
patch it. Cool. Right.
I think we can kind of afford to just
chill and do some general refactoring
for a few hours.
because
like for the most part
we want this sweep to finish. We want to
verify some results
and
we'll want to run 2048 sweep.
We'll want to see those results and if
stuff is relatively sane again,
we'll be good. If not, it'll be a few
more tweaks.
And it's mostly clean up from there.
Mostly clean up.
It looks like we're making good time.
I'd say we're making good time overall
then.
Yeah.
Okay. I'm going to go get some tea. I'm
use a restroom. I'll be back in a few
and then we will continue on some
refactors.
Uh this is also this is 550 experiments
just while I've been live. So nice and
speedy.
It's pretty close here.
I think the um additional tuning
we're going to be able to get this under
3 seconds
for sure.
It works so far.
It's a thought of so good.
Refactor and chill.
Get some music maybe.
Let me think what else there is to do.
No, because
well it depends how much of it is going
to be clawed versus manual.
Do I have more stuff that needs clotting
or can it just be manual by now?
Let's try some stuff manual and we'll
see if we find any jank that's like
super. So the thing is that like anytime
when do I use claude, right? It's when
sh when [ __ ] is super redundant.
Um, that's when you get clawed.
The goal is to get the code to not be
super redundant,
but that's easier said than done when
you're working with torch.
I mean, I suppose I could allow myself
to um
Okay, there's one last thing I want to
just check with claws because it's
probably a waste of time, but
My intuition is it's like a medium
amount of work
and I don't want to do it this patch
unless we happen to finish up early.
And I don't think unless this is like,
oh, that's super easy. I actually just
do this and I go, oh, I'm a goober. I
don't think we're going to do this now.
I just want to have this in mind. And
then what we'll do is we'll just kind of
go through and clean up some uh
we'll just kind of like go through and
start cleaning up stuff in
monkey type. It's like 90 max, man. It's
not great
I guarantee you that's achievable by
literally anybody because I promise you
you've not you've like never met anybody
with as bad fine motor skills as me.
Okay.
I'll let try it
and I'll see what it looks like.
Um,
if this is going to take any substantial
amount of time, we're not doing this
now. Uh, I said that we were going to
delay this for like future updates. The
only reason we're doing this now, like
at all, is because it might literally be
less work than figuring out how to clean
up stuff around.
Would you watch? No. 24. I'm not
watching that thing.
I I think that this is actually going to
end up being like sort of medium
complexity
because it's not for intermediate
activation tensors, right?
I think they're quite a lot of
intermediate activations.
But you know what I want to do?
I want to see the um
if the line count is shorter even with
clawed shitty version of this
AI summit.
You looking?
I'm not going to Delhi for an AI summit,
my guy.
I'm barely traveling domestically for
conferences these days, let alone
internationally.
What would it take for me to want to
like fully commit to doing
custom
knowing what will happen.
Any really what
is this? The Nvidia one or what?
Uh we're just going to see if you can
just drop torch autoat entirely real
quick, Jess. We're going to see what
happens.
I mean, because like essentially I've
refactored this to the point now that
it's not doing very much for us. So,
I'm going to have to spend a substantial
time in the next couple of weeks
cleaning up puffer. And it is actually
possible now that it is simpler uh to
drop the autograd and clean that up than
it is to clean up towards with autograd.
Mug holds a single tea bag.
kind of. I mean, I did one this I've had
three mugs of it and I like started with
one tea bag and I just added a new one
every time.
So, it was probably slightly stronger by
the third mug, but not by much
Black tea does not have more caffeine
than coffee. Not even close.
Unless you're drinking the world's
strongest tea and the world's weakest
coffee.
Okay, I'm going to let it do this.
Uh, and we're just going to essentially
see if the code's shorter or longer.
If the code ends up being shorter uh,
and the same speed or about the same and
much faster or anything like that, then
we will consider
because
the autograd is the source of much pain
at the moment.
I don't want caffeine. I'm intentionally
drinking um weekly caffeinated stuff.
I've had way too much caffeine in the
past.
How we doing on this?
Any good runs?
Looks to be about 4.3 seconds is best
you can do
and around five to be comfortable.
little weird that it's um
like not immediately faster,
but I think the other one was very well
optimized and it was also kind of janky,
right? Like I don't think it was super
stable. So I think there was more RNG in
the other one.
I think it was four or five seconds in
practice.
What are we going to Actually, what are
we going to do if this does work, right?
I guess then we would just we'd keep
torch
C++
for um
the native path.
I actually I think that the initial
version of this will be
maybe slightly more code.
We're at like 125 128 something like
that on um on the low end machine.
There's so many things we haven't even
touched yet for this, man. We haven't
even tried um horizon.
We can totally change horizon. We
haven't really tried the number of
buffers.
There's so much stuff we can Okay.
This would actually make it easier,
wouldn't it?
In some sense,
we'd have like a really nice
self-contained piece of CUDA code.
We can bind it to torch at whatever
level we want without having to deal
with it in the middle.
We can probably just export the graph
version of it to uh Python directly.
I actually I am not sure what I'm going
to do yet for um like baselines and
fallbacks, right? Because
We have our full native which has all
our kernels. We've got a C++ fallback
that you could run.
I could have a pure Python like pure
PyTorch version that you could run. And
we might even want that just to
benchmark how much faster we are than
torch.
Um,
I could also export, you know, just our
core network and stuff and I could have
that be in PyTorch. Like, so we could
essentially just say, "Hey, provided
you're not changing our core network, we
can get you half the speed in pure
Python." Maybe something like that.
Really, I think that the most important
thing though at the moment is just
getting these sweeps done because
as soon as we have confidence that uh
the sweeps are now good and that the
hypers are no longer jank and we start
getting results in the right direction,
then we're pretty much like locked on
release and everything else becomes
pretty high confidence.
And it's just a matter of getting the
work done.
right,
I'm fine with that.
Uh, except on is fine for this because
if this doesn't work, we're just going
to revert and say screw it. Anyways,
we're going to consider this like an
experimental for the hell of it for fun
thing.
And if this doesn't work in like an hour
of invested time and we don't see signs
of life, then we just won't bother.
It would be really cool though.
It'd be really cool.
And then it wouldn't even be like I
wouldn't even be wasting time at that
point, right? Because the amount of time
I would spend cleaning stuff up to be uh
native would just be the amount of time
I would spend like working around torch
trying to clean crap up, right?
Wouldn't
In gaming, this is known as a zero
timing.
All right. So, it is going to add a fair
bit of code for the manual backwards
initially at least.
I suspect it's going to end up shorter
though in the long term
in the not so long term.
And that is super simple code, you know,
if you're looking at it.
That is like super simple code.
No C++ classes,
no like janky vari
[ __ ]
Nothing.
No.
What's missing to go 100% cuda? Almost
nothing. Liberty.
Almost nothing.
Uh, okay. So, that matches,
but it's actually slower,
Why are we not stitching torch period.
So, we definitely need to bind to it
either way, Jess. It's just a question
of how much of it we strip out. Like, it
could literally be that we strip the
entire thing and then just it's hover
and then bind to torch. So people can
also extend with torch if they want.
Oh, wait. It wrapped. Hang on.
Did it wrap their weird autograd?
I bet it wrapped their autograd and like
is still doing that overhead plus
Oh, it's allocating every single step as
well.
So, this can definitely get optimized.
That's such a flex.
Hang on.
Is this what they do?
I want to make sure we're actually
isolating
autograd overhead
like the shirt. Thank you.
The shirts are all Vory.
which I guess it's like a trendy
whatever now, but I don't know. I found
Bor when it was just like they just had
a couple stores before they blew up.
It's the only place I actually like
shopping. I swear cuz they actually have
new stuff that's like good and
comfortable.
I think the only complaint I have with
their is that the uh the like shorts and
thin sweats don't last very long if you
run in them.
Everything else is pretty awesome.
Yeah, these are the Strato TE's. The one
other thing is the heaviest wet pants
they have. I forget what they're called,
but the These wets are like really nice.
They also make the world's most
comfortable pajamas, but only for women,
which sucks.
We're just going to let it do all this
[ __ ]
and then we'll see where we end up.
Are we faster?
Are we uh functional?
Let's see.
this where we were at before? Said we
were at like 13 mil,
12 to 13 mil.
So, it's now same speed, right?
there's no reason to expect it to not
work.
I guess the only question is the
magnitude of the speed ups that we
should expect from this.
I guess we'll just look at the code
after and see if this is worth it.
We wanted to do this eventually. The
question is just do we do this now or
not?
I said it's been an hour on it. What's
it been? 30 40 minutes.
Not even.
We'll give it a little bit of time.
Initial results are like pretty decent.
So this is the new if we kept this the
new PO loss would be like this right
it's one function
you have your launch directly in here
how much do you code manually versus
using claude well it depends if the code
base I'm dealing with is a complete
piece of crap then uh there's a bunch of
clawing Unfortunately,
if you see me writing C Sims, very
little.
Right now, we're in a transitional phase
where torch is a piece of crap. The
thing I'm trying to build should not end
up being a piece of crap. And getting it
from one to the other is really
obnoxious.
You definitely don't want to make the
mistake though of thinking that the
models are like good programmers or
smart or capable of sophisticated
reasoning because they're totally not.
They're really stupid.
But they've read the entire torch source
code without getting bored.
How do you approach CIMS? What's your
strategy? Write the code in the
simplest, dumbest way possible from top
to bottom. And don't allocate uh memory
all over the place in the loop like a
goober.
When you first started 40, what would
you tell
Um,
yo, this is going to totally suck.
You're going to learn a lot. You're
going to spend a bunch of time getting
bullshitted by Torch.
I don't think I could like, it's a lot
of information is the thing. Like, the
extent to which Torch is just truly
utterly garbage is very difficult to
convey.
I mean, how do you convey I'm going to
have to write a really big long article
ultimately for the release because how
do I convey that every single possible
portion of Torch is just complete and
utter crap and they've made every wrong
decision they could possibly make.
There's not a single time I've gone and
looked at torture and gone, "Oh, wow,
that's pretty clever. That cooks pretty
clean." Not a single time.
It's going to be a nice long article,
Jess. Probably multiple.
I mean, there's a good chance I just end
up spending a week writing
Spencer's going to kill me for doing
this. I swear. He's going to be like,
"Why are youing replacing torch?"
But um I think it's literally going to
be easier than refactoring the code
around torch.
We'll see. I like I said, we'll give it
a little bit of time.
Uh if this if this is actually somewhat
faster and is not broken though, then
this is motive to keep it right here
because I tried to do this exact same
operation with torch beforehand. I spent
uh an hour doing it with torch and I
couldn't do it because torch was a mess.
Does it affect the existing ends? Uh, it
really doesn't. The thing is there's
very little required on existing M grit.
There's a very small port up to 40, but
like I'll just do it for everybody
because it's super easy.
It's very, very little change.
The networks change,
a lot of other stuff changes. Real
opportunity for the prime prime vid.
I mean, he seems chill.
I actually when I was like moving off of
Python, some of his videos were quite
helpful.
I think like a lot of the reason I
started like trying out more procedural
programming was some of his stuff.
Like you got to understand I was not
trained as a systems programmer. Uh I
had very very little low-level dev
experience
and
I I did spend about a decade just trying
to figure out how to write better
simpler code and actually caring about
that not just sort of brushing it off as
you know code is the means to the end.
So I sort of had my mind in roughly the
right spot a lot of the time.
So it was very very natural for me to go
to sea. It was actually like a very
natural change.
It only took a few weeks before it was
super chill. And then most of the
problems I've had have not been in the
lowle depth. Most of the problems I've
had have been interfacing with all the
other crap out there. Right.
him to promote you.
I don't know. He's probably chilling
somewhere.
No, you don't run setup. I run stuff.
is that a little faster? I think that
was a little faster.
Yeah, it's a little faster.
Let's see what the code looks like.
This is sadly this is going to end up
having to be very very heavily clogged
crap until um we get it into a new form.
It'll mostly be remixing my own code,
which is at least something.
What did it do? Wait, did it take out
photographs?
No.
Okay, it still has photographs.
Can it? We can do contiguous RAD buffers
now, right?
I'll tell you what, it's only 2 p.m.
Um, this looks promising.
I got a bunch of stuff done earlier
today. I will allow myself to run this
like to do this experiment of seeing
what happens if I go down this path.
Worst case scenario,
I lose a few hours and I have a very
good understanding of the challenges
that I face for Puffer 4 and it better
informs how I'm going to refactor the
old version. Best case scenario, we make
Puffer significantly faster. We make the
code simpler and I get to stop bitching
about torch being a piece of crap all
the time because we won't be relying on
it in the ways that we were.
And you all get to see something kind of
entertaining, which is like toward
actually not doing things and getting
stripped out.
Let me see if I'm actually correct.
Oh, look. It's Wait, grab logics.
Hypers kernels
radic
Let's see.
encoder.
We still have register module
forward tra.
Oh, we have the manual buffers. Okay,
hang on.
In that case,
cuz that was the other big update that I
wanted. I wanted to have it be
contiguous.
That's
I think that this works.
And then what we would have um move on
can just write back into the same one,
right?
I think that works.
Way too much [ __ ] plotting here.
But
the good news is we are trending towards
the direction of less torch [ __ ]
that requires this
because like I keep having to make these
big refactors to work around torch crap
but I keep reducing the amount of torch.
So in theory as we approach zero torch
there should be less reason to need this
stuff.
Sir, Brad, this should be noticeably
faster.
This should literally be like
I mean that's actually a pretty big
buff, isn't it? Contiguous brand buffer.
I remember continuous weight buffer
being a pretty big buff. Contrib buffer
should definitely be a big buff.
That'd be pretty cool,
right?
I bet you it screwed up though cuz I
didn't see it updating. Um,
it didn't update the policy, did it?
Yes, this doesn't work full, but that's
expected.
Oh yeah, we can at least beat Jack
though, right?
See, now I think it's doing both. So,
it's slower because I think it's doing
both things. It's writing into the
non-ontiguous and it's doing the
continuous.
We probably even can optimize further by
um doing the is one big cast.
We shall see
accumulate. Yeah, that gets away.
The copy handles the cast
and then directly writes into the
buffer.
Ask codebase about the code base and
learn what each what
code Yes.
Read the functions, man. The snake end.
It's first year undergrad level C.
There's nothing fancy in that end. I
promise you. If you just read that file
from top to bottom, it will be very
simple.
I thought the graph had accumulated in
FP32.
It probably just forgot to like
put these into the buffer or whatever,
right?
Yeah. Look like the default encoder,
the default decoder.
Training inference functions are
basically untouched which is super good.
Uh this manual buffers thing is
going to get overwritten anyways.
I'm use the restroom real quick while
this does whatever. And uh grab a new
mug of tea. We will continue. I will be
back.
This thing has just been chilling for um
seven minutes doing nothing,
which is kind of cool. I went I made
myself another a new mug of tea. I came
back and it's still doing nothing.
That's kind of silly.
Now, this is the problem with uh these
stupid models,
but I can totally see it, right? Like
it's just not using the uh the grab
buffers for encoder
and decoder, right?
Yeah. It needs to define a backward
function.
I don't know why it's just stuck doing
nothing.
Is this control O?
Wait, how is it this stupid? Are you
kidding me? It's done all this crap.
Dude, this is such an obvious thing. Why
is it so dumb?
Okay,
hang on. Let's make I'm not dumb.
Port kernel,
backward kernel,
you know.
Let's see.
Let's figure out why this thing is
messed up.
Backward manual.
Buffer li policy. Backward manual.
Oh, it does have the encoder backward,
right?
Wait,
it does have the encoder backward.
I'm sorry.
So that's why it's confused.
I think that would seem weird to me.
So, it's just thrashing.
Why set requires grad.
We're probably mixing auto brad.
Yeah, this has got
no brad guard.
We'll sort this out. It's actually a lot
of stuff is going to get much much
simpler, believe it or not.
I don't have accept edits on. I don't
know why it just like is allowed to do
this.
Not prevented when stream is capturing.
Lovely.
Two layers. Oh, those are literally our
only params, huh?
That'd be funny if we broke stream
somehow.
Let's see if it works. Could grab ball.
I mean, that would be the best guess
would be that it's still doing auto red
somewhere, right?
Then our entire thing gets to run under
no bread, which is cool.
Hey Antonio, we're attempting to replace
torch because I think it's going to be
easier than working around torch. These
torches auto. We'll keep their tensors
for now.
The funny thing is that if we did
replace it completely, that would also
fix our compile times.
optimize tensor somehow.
Uh in cudigraph mode, there shouldn't be
anything to optimize.
Um yeah,
noncuda graph you could very well
optimize. You could probably get the
non-graft path to be very very close and
b to the graft path and then just not
need paths and not need the cudigraph
path. That'd be pretty cool.
still? This is the best one.
We got a lot of pumps over here, though.
4.3 seconds.
was pretty good.
Twothirds of the way done with the
sweep. I think I set it up to run 1,200
experiments.
Much nicer than before at the very least
with the hypers.
So assuming we can fix this bug in
relatively short order. Um,
Figure out what we do with non-cernels
and how we do that whole shenanigans.
Probably that makes um probably that's
actually going to put us in a pretty
good spot.
we would just like
export
We'd export like a few poor things, I
suppose.
Like we do the graph loss for instance,
or was it the loss? One kernel doesn't
even need to be graphed. So we'd export
this. We'd export the
the network forward backward I guess.
Couple
other things
I can think about the Python stuff after
it's kind of secondary.
I swear they just set it on like, you
know, pay us free money mode or whatever
cuz it's not doing anything.
Yeah. Why the [ __ ] is it even doing
this, man?
Brad deck out buff.
What?
Just the recursive self-improvement is
just going to be when there exists code
in reinforcement learning that is fast.
It doesn't suck and we can go, "Oh,
that's pretty simple. Now this makes
sense. What if I try this, this, and
that? Oh, wow. Look, the field's way
better. Isn't it awesome when you have
fast code that doesn't suck that you can
actually understand?
That's what's going to happen. It's just
a lot of work to get there.
Yeah.
Oh, that's what you mean. Recursive
self-improvement not of the RL code but
of the agents. I mean, that is something
we can actually think about.
Hey bros on Twitter. Well, I don't mean
recursive self-improvement in the sense
that just like oh it shs everything
somehow being trained on breakout,
right? I mean like you get something
that continues to make progress over
time more rapidly in a hard environment
as it starts learning the dynamics
same language.
Yeah.
I mean, well, those guys have no
grounding whatsoever in reality.
Okay, this what it's checking here is
what I actually wanted to check. If this
doesn't work, we're just going to go
back to the um uh joint buffers and then
try again.
I can like I'm starting to be able to
see in my head what this code is going
to be able to look like. And it's so
much better than this stuff, man. It's
so much better than this.
I know I'm going to have to pay like
just like stock this thing another 100
bucks. It's going to have just like
wasted 100 bucks on nothing today, I'm
sure.
But whatever.
doesn't find anything in the backward
kernel though. We'll just go back to the
original and we'll not use the grad
buffer at
It's just in a rabbit doing [ __ ]
nothing.
It's so stupid. Okay.
It's literally like
it's like if you read the words it's
like very well put together like oh yeah
it's doing things but if you actually
look at the content it makes absolutely
no sense at all.
Oh, great. So, we just lose the whole
thing, huh?
Now, this is what I get for losing
Claude like an utter imbecile. Um,
this is why you don't do this.
I need to get torch garbage C++ modern
C++ and all this bloated crap out of my
workflow and then ye these stupid models
with it.
Okay, they did actually include a
feature. So, good on them for once.
Well, it was training before on this
version and it's not training now.
So,
We'll start from here and we'll actually
be a lot more explicit about everything
because it seems like this does work.
Um, it's just going to take a little bit
of effort. I'll be back.
I guess I do need to have that as a
sanity.
Yeah,
We kind of have to we do it this way.
Hang on. If I keep it like this for now.
It's a shitty intermediate build, isn't
it?
Yeah, I think what we want is we want to
have
we want to have a full native version so
we can kind of see where the code is
going to and see that we are actually
producing something simpler. And then
we'll have a much more complicated
version that we'll use for back testing
and crap.
But I need to be able to see the simple
version like ASAP
and see where it's going.
908.
It's looking pretty good.
That's their maximum number of points.
So, I don't know if it actually has all
the points on here.
Yeah, because this this will end up
being actually pretty simple.
I think we're basically going to be able
to replace it though.
Yeah, we will pretty much be just able
to replace it.
just go.
Sounds good. Yeah, I didn't want to do
this in 40, but it kind of it became
obvious that one, we're leaving some
perf on the table, and two, like I don't
want to spend two weeks cleaning up the
code to be as good as possible for it to
like still be kind of crap because of
torch.
Like, it's going to take me the same
amount of time to just get it into
something that's clean and doesn't
really heavily depend on torch. I mean,
we'll probably still use their tensor
class,
Maybe.
I'm just trying to figure out how I want
to do the um
still happy to give 21st. Yes. Keep
reminding me so I remember to make my
talk fit
because I've been thinking about what I
want to do, but I have to actually like
make a talk.
Okay,
it's actually
I might just have to do a morning
session tomorrow honestly
on this. It's just so much work.
It's like every think I've got
everything the way I wanted. I go,
you know, this kind of sucks.
Come on.
Forgot the bindings, dude.
I need to leave.
It's only 3:40.
I mean, the good news about this is we
will legitimately just end up with like
upper lib.cu or whatever.
It should be very very short now that
I'm thinking about it.
Yes. Okay.
Name parameters.
Okay, this still works.
We're happy
this works.
This is unfortunately going to be a lot
of like hacky nonsense here.
The final version of this I have in my
head is going to look like it's going to
look very very simple,
but getting there takes some work.
Since this is not strictly strictly
necessary to the project, um I think
what I'm going to do to compensate for
any time offset that this would take,
which I don't think would really be
much, but um just in case like this ends
up taking me a couple extra days, I'm
just going to put in some extra hours uh
over the weekend and early next week
to compensate.
I mean, this is actually genuinely
exciting to me, though. Um, because if
we can get Torch out of there, like the
idea of just having clean, simple RL
code is so so good.
It's like so important and Torch makes
it so freaking difficult.
But I think I'm kind of seeing the way
that we're going to be able to do it and
we're going to be able to keep our stuff
torch compatible for the most part
um without making it a mess.
Like essentially, right, it's just we
write our code the simplest way possible
and then we're going to bind to torch.
The torch binds are allowed to be a mess
because it's torch's fault. Damn it.
And in the meantime, we still get to
just finish like keep running all these
experiments and I don't have to pull
this code on the remote machine where
I'm doing this
and I can just kind of run our new
experiments.
And then on the new version,
we basically just have to make sure that
our optimized runs repro
uh which is super quick. And then we'll
know everything is stable. And we can
even compare the uh the timings because
it should be a little bit faster. Just a
little bit.
And we're getting a very nice paro curve
here. It seems like 4.3 seconds is the
fastest on this though.
There's wombie overhead and other stuff
though. Maybe not the worst.
Clear contact. Hang on.
The bar on this is going to be so high
for the simplicity
cuz if I'm going to give people
something that doesn't look like the
thing that they're familiar with, it has
to be so freaking obviously better it's
not even close.
I do wonder if we're going to even end
up needing photographs by the end of
this.
It sort of depends.
It's wrong.
Oh, no. Wait, it's not done.
The goal is to freaking completely
delete torch at which point I won't need
it.
I basically I got it very very close and
then I looked at it and I'm like it's
going to take me two weeks to manually
clean up this code in order to only have
have something like I'm only kind of
okay with
cuz like of all the torch jank
like it'll literally be the same amount
of work pretty much to just replace
torch at this point
cuz torch is doing basically Basically
nothing.
I could honestly even replace their
tensor class. Uh, and even that wouldn't
be that hard.
Why replace it is jank? because it's
literally forcing me to write slower,
longer, worse code.
Trying to make torch fast is literally
more complicated than replacing it.
It's so bad. There's literally not like
when you're doing actual high
performance stuff on nets of various
sizes, including small ones, there it
has just no redeeming qualities. There's
not a single goddamn design decision
that they made correctly.
I mean, I need to get this like
continuous buffer thing to work
because the thing is until I have the
continuous buffer thing working,
I'm still sort of dependent on
um like parameter handling and stuff
and I get rid of that we're set
then I can get rid of their linear
I can actually get access to the um the
maple functions that take out params so
we can have static buffers
should actually get a fair bit faster
even
hell of a lot simpler
Let's see if you actually found the B or
if you just hallucinated some [ __ ]
it works.
Good.
We're going to make a quick commit.
Jack, Slack, and Torch. There's no
comparison. Um, Jax is just straight
trolling. That shit's awful. Look, at
least Torch's lowlevel back end sucks.
At least they have.
If I had to do this [ __ ] in Jacks, it's
just I [ __ ] quit. I'm gonna go pick
another field. Like
as much as I rag on the meta engineers
that like over complicate the crap out
of Torch and make everything slow for no
reason, like at least they're not the
Google bro that think they're geniuses
writing Jacks.
making a proper torch replacement. It's
going to be pretty close, Jess. Like the
thing is you don't need torch but
better, right? That's the key thing.
Like you need not torch. Like 90% of the
stuff that's in there just doesn't need
to exist and you're better off without
it.
there's very very little you actually
need.
It's like, "Oh, but it's so convenient."
Well, is it convenient when you have to
end up writing more code that is slower,
dealing more with more APIs that suck,
that shouldn't exist? Like, no,
not at all. Like you basically need a
tensor strct and you need some kernels
and that's it.
This is fine because we never have to
accumulate in activations. We only have
to copy
We'll see if this breaks it or not.
Something more complicated. There's not
way to to make that not bloat.
Uh
Okay. Yes. To be fair, Jess, you could
make a decent auto. You're right.
You could make a decent autograph.
I suppose autograd itself isn't
fundamentally screwed. It's the
implementation of this autograph that is
screwed. That is fair. That said, I do
think the importance of autograd uh is
vastly overstated,
but it is true that uh it's pretty easy
to have annoying errors by doing the
like the grads manual like fine.
At least I think it is conceivable that
a decent autograd that you would use for
some stuff could exist. That's about the
strongest you can get.
Well, because Jess, if you get like
literally anything wrong with it, you're
better off not having it. That's the
problem.
mini badge segments.
I don't know why it's getting rid of
this, but cool.
Oh, okay. It just moved it up. That's
fine.
interface with it more. No, it's the
design chest. It's down to the core.
Everything's allocated all over the pl
all over the place uh in fragmented
memory. uh activation buffers are
dynamically allocated and destroyed all
over the place. Uh the stuff that you
need to like make it fast doesn't work
and is only in Python anyways and comes
with a compile compile your Python time
overhead. Uh it doesn't actually fuse
operations the way it's supposed to to
make it fast. If you write custom
kernels to fuse your operations, it
makes it hell by introducing a really
clunky modules API that's like makes you
write hundreds of lines of boilerplate
crap everywhere. Um,
their mixed precision doesn't even exist
in the C++. You have to write your own.
That also means you basically have to do
your own optimizer. Their distributed is
literally harder than adding your own
distributed in and slower.
What else?
Oh yeah, cudigraphing is absolute and
utter hell because they have their own
cudigraphing rappers and do a bunch of
weird stuff with your cuda streams. You
have to cudigraph because every single
opinor has a bunch of checks and [ __ ]
that bloat everything ludicrously.
That's just most of the stuff off the
top of my head in front of me. It's
pretty much everything. Anything you
point to is wrong.
You point to it, it's wrong. It's that
Okay, cool. So now we have this linear.
Nice.
It's R&M subclass as well.
I think so. No.
I will write I will write a good
article. Yep. I will write a good
article.
It's putting stuff all over the place in
really dumb spots, but we don't care for
now.
I wonder if it clears the buffer.
It probably if I were in like
implementing it probably doesn't.
Well, if it doesn't run, we'll know why.
But we're going to be able to do these
in contiguous memory and do it all in
one zero hop which will be faster
ultimately.
Got to be
We are probably going to dip a little
bit of perf on here temporarily. Uh this
will be faster ultimately. It will
essentially have to be. But a couple of
these things are not implemented
optimally right now.
like certain chunks of buffers need to
be zeroed together, certain buffers need
to not be zeroed,
but this is what you essentially want
here.
I wouldn't be surprised if you drop a
fair bit of perk doing this.
Well, let's see if it's actually even
stable.
Okay, good.
You do drop a little bit of perf, but
not really much for having it not
implemented efficiently. I will be right
back. Let me use the restroom and then
we will uh I got a little bit longer
before dinner. I'll be back.
I'm just trying to get the like the
basic stuff that I know needs to be
there consistent.
Hey, mortal. Welcome.
We are
well, we're rewriting very large chunks
of torch at this point.
And I'm using this crap to like hack
something together quickly.
Um, but then if we get if we essentially
if we get this thing looking fixable and
uh hitting perf targets roughly, then
this will be what I end up doing and
I'll end up cleaning it up a lot
manually.
Well, in passes, right? I probably do
course refactoring with this stupid
thing and then fine grain refactor
manually.
Yeah, you definitely need to do there
definitely need to be two activation
buffers though, right?
Like
there should be an activation buff.
There needs to be a buffer for stuff
that gets zeroed and a buffer for stuff
that doesn't essentially
Yeah, we get rid of a bunch of zero
faults this way. I think three zero PS
get deleted.
Oh yeah. How's your sweep going?
Almost done.
Oh, we did get um 852 in 2.98 seconds.
So, we're kind of getting the burrito
front nicely here. Yeah.
Like right.
Where is it? Come on. Yeah. There's your
burrito front.
The orthogonal is for Yeah,
orthogonalization is for Muan.
This may or may not be noticeably
faster, but it is faster
in general.
Okay, it just like inline the encoder,
which is stupid, but whatever.
Yeah, it inlined everything because it's
stupid. Um, so this like most of this
will end up going in the min group
instead of inside the whole loop.
Once that is done correctly,
uh, this will all be fine. I think
backward. Perfect. Yeah, this will be
fine.
Oh, this is Justin. Hello,
welcome. I am uh attempting to fix a
bunch of stuff in torch. I couldn't find
many papers and using muon for nonLMR
applications. From my experience, looks
like it kind of took longer to convert,
but have more exploration
eventually switch. So, uh you have to
retune the hypers. We have a blog post
on this in Puff Mar. It was a step
change for us. Like Muan was way way
better um for Puffer than Adam. We could
technically go try those experiments
again, but I'm pretty confident it
should be better. Uh it should not take
any longer if you have a correct
implementation of Muon. Like Muan itself
is quite fast. It's a very small amount
of overhead. Um it's just the
orthogonalization step which
over each mini batch. So, it's a
constant amount of time per mini batch.
It doesn't like if you have tiny mini
batches, it'll be slow. If you have
normal big RL mini batches, it'll be
fine. Um, and Adam W I don't see the
point in because you almost are never
using weight decay in RL. Use heavy
ball. Yeah, heavy ball works. It's just
very bloated and complicated. Went over
my articles. It's just popping up PO,
right?
I think I just it was detailed in where
is it? JS
in the wrong browser.
Let me find it
And I think we have the thing is you can
implement here. Try this one.
I think I still have it.
You can just copy this into your code
and see if it works for you.
Uh, muan.py. high.
Try this.
This is 150 lives and it's the uh same
muan as heavy ball has.
You have to sweep the hypers,
but yeah, heavy ball is just really
really freaking bloated. Now, I don't
know if my implementation is fast in
Python to be fair. Um, my C++ one will
be very fast.
So take that for what you will but it is
it it doesn't exist. It is there.
I got half an hour. Then I got to get
start getting ready.
IRS in a few weeks. Not going to have
time to try to tune it. We'll experiment
after.
Yeah. The reason you don't have time to
tune it though is because your stuff is
slow. Right here. Look at this. This is
um this is puffer 4. All right. I
started this sweep this morning. It has
1,086 experiments completed already.
And we can see that we saw a breakout
and best time of 4.28 uh 4.29 seconds.
And then of course breakout is the fast
experiment. will run overnight. We'll
run on a harder environment
and we'll see if it checks out on a
harder M. We have lots of M's to use.
Kale and entropy.
I don't really look at Kale and entropy
a ton. Honestly,
manually tuning hyperparameters is kind
of just raw.
Once we get all of this into static
memory,
first of all, we should get a bit of a
speed bump.
Uh, I can then start refactoring this
stuff.
It'll end up looking about the same
complexity.
No, I think even simpler than it was
before.
It'll take a bit of work. It's there
though. I mean, like the whole cudamog
walls like it's all kind of a bit of a
mess.
quite a bit in robotics, exploration,
RL.
Is this your first or second year um
PhD? I forget.
second year.
Hopefully things are going well.
I don't know if you've seen I have um I
have RL at like uh 15 to 20 mill steps
per second now.
Walls ah fun first nonworkshop paper is
good.
[ __ ] Yeah, it's really fast. I pretty
much am having to replace torch though.
I hate that I'm here typing crap into
claw, but um
it's basically Torch's mess that I'm
cleaning up with this. My hope is that
once I get this into clean standalone
CUDA, uh it's going to require little or
no AI to clean this stuff up more.
But it's a non-trivial architecture as
well, man. This is not like, oh, I made
a, you know, a linear one layer network
or whatever. No, this is Mingru. It's
got recurrent state. You can stack it.
You can stack it like four layers deep,
still 15 million. Um,
solves all like the simple classic tasks
in seconds.
Smaller versions of it can push over 20
mil steps per second. I've seen up to 23
mil.
It's pretty nice.
But I pretty much I got all that stuff
done and then I realized like man I
cannot make this code as good as I want
to make it because of Torch. So not only
is Torch making it a little bit slower
than it should be, it's also just making
it way more complicated than it should
be. That's really not doing anything for
us anymore.
The heck
why is this getting this?
Aren't there torch CPP bindings? Yes,
they're slow. We tried that.
Pretty much every single part of Torch,
including the internal C++,
uh is just bad, poorly designed, and
slow.
This is also going to have instant
startup time pretty much which is
awesome. Like you're not going to have
to do forge compile type stuff. Your
experiments will just have instant
startup time as well because you're not
running a jet.
Oh jeez.
Probably was trying to do too much
break. We'll see.
Yeah, tried to do way too much at once.
I should have just had to do one of
those things. We'll see. Maybe we get
lucky and it works.
Lights out and
manually playable. Cool.
Building some MS is a really good way to
um learn some lowle dev, learn some
morale.
A lot of the ms end up being very useful
as well.
We'll see if this works. I probably just
try to do way too much.
Perf is not better, which is a problem,
but
I think it's okay for now. It's not
really much worse.
And um presumably this is doing a ton of
stupid things that I'm going to have to
check.
So this is bothering me the um the
policy here.
Like it'll just do stupid stuff like
this,
you know.
Still going to take quite a bit of work,
I think.
Matching parameters order.
Why do we need to be matching parameters
order?
Yeah, dot parameters in sketch. Like
what the heck uses dot parameters?
At least we will have an idea what the
hell it's doing by the time I'm done
with this, which will be out of the
workflow.
It's annoying. Like basically every time
I start getting it cleaned up, I start
doing stuff manually and everything is
good and every time there's a major
refactor need. But every time there's a
major refactor needed because I hit
support [ __ ] It's like, well, I'm
not leaving this in the way it is.
Right.
Let's figure out what the heck uses
parameters. Stop building.
I figure out what the heck uses
parameters.
Good.
Little better even
solves.
right. Yeah, I got to get ready to uh to
go in.
We'll just go through this class thing.
I don't think we're going to get all of
this done today.
I'll probably just put in some time in
the morning um on my own and
just like see if we can get the basic
end to end set up for this
and then thinking about cleaning it up a
little bit.
I mean the cool thing here is that we're
using so a little from torch that at
this point it's basically you just write
a single CUDA file that does a few
initialization methods
um
no binds blast matt a couple other very
small things and you're
It's not even added a ton of um it's not
even added like a ton a ton of code
though. I think that my objective here
I'd like to actually be slower by the
time I'm done with it, which I would
think it should be able to be cuz we're
not going to have any of the modules
prep. I just wanted to push it to a
branch so we don't lose stuff.
I think this is a good stopping point
because here this is a nice clean
summary. I can go off of this. There's
several spots in here where like all
these contiguouses are just going to be
checks asserts instead of like this is a
oh just in case callontiguous. No, that
makes stuff slow. So I'm going to go
through manually. I'm going to spend
some time probably in the morning
tomorrow going through all this. Um, and
the goal is that everything is fully
static, which is what Peru suggested to
me. It's going to look a little
different from his imple, but we'll get
there. Um,
I got to talk to him for sure about some
stuff.
And
yeah, we shall see. We shall see. For
folks who tuned in, thank you very much.
Uh, if you're interested in my work and
you'd like to support me for absolutely
free, feed the puff or a star on GitHub
really helps me out. Stream tomorrow
undecided. I'm supposed to at least take
a day off a week and I haven't done that
the last two weeks. So, we shall see.
Uh, Discord here if you want to get
involved with dev or you can follow me
on X, which I need to update this link
because I got my new handle. It's just
JS Bars, no 5341.
And follow me right here. I got a bunch
of articles and stuff. All right, thank
you. You all have a nice evening on
Valentine's Day.